right you know and I and I sit down with
with guys in our company that are young
they come in guys and girls and the
first three lessons we have a three-part
video series they watch their first day
at work and the three-part video series
is destroying delusion one destroying
delusion 2 and destroying delusion three
and I say my goal for you when you start
working here is to divorce your
delusions right divorce your delusions
from you like I want to point you to
like you're gonna say well this works
this works this works but I'm going to
show you what actually works okay that's
it and some people go through that and
they are thankful what are the delusions
oh there's like there's like for example
uh there's one let's talk about sales
for a second there's one delusion that
like knocking on doors and selling
doesn't work like oh people don't buy
like that anymore everybody just buys on
dinner that's just like